yesterday joe biden made a major
announcement that should have roiled
world markets when he casually told the
world that he has cancer
my mother drove us and rather than us be
able to walk
and guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
it had to put on their windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i had so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer and white
camp for the longest time delaware had
the highest cancer rate in the nation
now the republican national committee
immediately picked up this statement and
raised the question hold on does biden
have cancer
which prompted the libs immediately to
go into damage control mode glenn
kessler who is the lead fact checker for
the washington post responded by asking
quote how dumb is this tweet from the
rnc check out biden's medical report
before he became president he'd had
non-melanoma skin cancers removed has no
one at the rnc ever had this common
procedure gosh this is crazy
but no matter how much spin the
washington post fact checker spun
he couldn't change what biden said
biden didn't say i had cancer i had
cancer in the past he said i have cancer
present tense
and the craziest part of all of it is
not that biden said that
it's not the announcement it's not that
the liberal fact checker was dishonest
his job is to check the facts and but he
was totally dishonest the craziest part
is that no one really seemed to care
the president of the united states
announced that he currently has cancer
and no one took it seriously because we
all know that he has dementia
we all just
sort of waited for the white house
staffers who were actually running the
country once again to contradict the
president which they did a few hours
later at which point the corrupt media
memory holds the president's comments
and went right back to their regularly
scheduled program i'm michael knowles
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from alison b who
says michael knowles's entire response
to the gop coward is in the house is
such a dad response i'm not mad
i'm just disappointed that's how i feel
it's how i feel congressman i'm not even
mad
i'm just
disappointed you know what never
disappoints me good ranchers right now
go to goodranchers.com
knowles in ronald reagan's farewell
address what did he say he said all
great change in america begins around
the dinner table will bring your family
to the dinner table with good ranchers
good ranchers cares deeply about
providing families with high quality
meat at a reasonable price when i was a
kid having steak was a special occasion
kind of a thing it was kind of a rarity
good ranchers makes that possible
all the time you can have steak multiple
times per week the quality is incredible
it's 100 american meat born raised and
harvested in the u.s right to your door
they age every cut to perfection gives
you that true steak house experience
right at home and then this is really
crazy when you subscribe your price is
locked in for the life of your
subscription we've got crazy inflation
all over the place today you can lock in
the price of your meat right now we're
talking ribeyes t-bones wagyu burgers
they're just it's so great i eat i eat
good ranchers multiple times per week
and i absolutely adore it right now use
my code knowles k-o-w-l-e-s
to get your steakhouse experience for 30
bucks off plus free shipping on your
order by the way shipping is not cheap
we're talking about a lot of very top
quality meat here so take advantage of
this incredible offer go to
goodranchers.com knowles start bringing
people back to the table and eating
seriously delicious food if you already
bought from good ranchers show me what
you are making post a photo of your meal
tag me as well as our friends over at
good ranchers so they can see it too
the announcement
was crazy from biden
the media response was pathetic although
expected the people who were supposed to
be reporting the facts and speaking
truth to power just immediately tried to
flack for this guy and lie and deceive
the american people that's that was
unfortunate
the the whole bit about
what the windshield wipers and the
oil slicks on his windshield and i mean
it's just it's very sad but if you've
ever had relatives who have suffered
from dementia you know this is just what
they sound like and so you just say oh
yeah
wow what did the oil slicks sound like
aunt sally great aunt sally we're the oh
gosh that's really interesting no you
haven't told me about the oil slicks
tell me about that
the media aspect though is
is really frustrating
because we in america
pride ourselves on our free press we
have a free press unlike those
oppressive countries you know there's
really bad countries where they have
state-controlled media well we have a
totally free press that's at least what
our press tells us
and yet i watched the news
and and i have to tell you sometimes
i wonder if we wouldn't have a more
honest media if we were living in north
korea i watched this clip yesterday from
kob 4 so it's one of these local news
affiliates a local news affiliate in new
mexico running a segment a news segment
on how you're supposed to completely
change all your language to deny reality
let's talk about dei in the workplace
and that's better known as diversity
equity and inclusion how do we go about
the discussion of pronouns so
essentially the employee will reach out
and say hey this is my preferred pronoun
this is how i would like to be
addressed in the workplace how we go
about it is by respecting their request
right so you want to make sure when they
say this is what i would like to be
referred to
we address it and we we honor that and
we
moving forward use that term whether
it's he she
they them their whatever they would like
to use we want to make sure we honor
that request and make them feel
comfortable in the workplace is it
appropriate for someone to ask what
someone's preferred pronoun usages are
you probably wouldn't want to ask that
person would ask you okay so you know if
you um if they haven't fully made the
decision on what pronoun they would like
to use let them come around to that
decision and then ask
if they haven't asked yet it's not safe
to assume we don't want to make any
assumptions we don't want to make any
assumptions that's great let's talk a
little bit more about
all of the language that people should
use and if they don't use that language
how they'll they're very bad people and
they'll be fired and how we need to deny
reality and call men women and women men
i would find the media more credible
if they were talking about how kim
il-sung is the eternal leader of north
korea
and is still alive governing his people
from the heavens
that would that is at least
as
fantastical
or at least as realistic as what you're
seeing here from the new mexico news
station
in fact in many ways the
state-controlled media in north korea
and china and russia and wherever all of
all of these terrible places on earth in
some ways they're more honest because at
least you know okay this is state-run
media
so take it with a grain of salt in
america it's it's in many ways worse
because they pretend to be a free press
and yet they push this kind of madness
this kind of corporate establishment
absurd
dishonest
madness that is propaganda you have to
see it the reason
i i harp on this i don't know probably
once a week we do at least some segment
on just
outright dishonesty in the media is you
you've you've got to puncture it you've
got to once you see through that it it
becomes a lot easier to deal with the
media because you just know when you
get a story from the new york times or
you get a story from the associated
press or you see a story trending on
twitter and it's from one of the special
verified credible sources from facebook
or twitter you just know how to read it
and you know what to discount and you
know what the angle is going to be and
you can know oh if he says this it
actually means the opposite and oh glenn
kessler said it well then it definitely
means the opposite and oh they're
talking about covid so here's where
they're going to be lying here's where
they're getting their money and you just
know where the powers are you want to
talk about covet this is the this is the
craziest covid story i have read in at
least four days
this story
it comes i have to be very careful about
how i speak about this because if i if i
say the wrong word it's kind of like in
that dei segment of new mexico if i use
the wrong pronoun if i use the wrong
word i will be censored this show will
be shut down off of social media and i
want to hit my million subscribers on
youtube so i'm going to be very careful
i'm going to use the language here in
the ap fact check
here is the claim
a swedish study
shows that pfizer's covid19 vaccine
changes recipients dna
that's a claim and the ap says this is
totally false
okay so what does the
what does the study do it says ap's
assessment false
well what's true there was the study
out of sweden
on the mrna covid vaccine
on the effect that the mrna cova vaccine
has on dna now i'm just quoting directly
from the ap you can't take me down
sensors
the study tested whether the vaccine's
mrna could be converted to dna
and found that this was the case
so yes it
it
it does change the dna that you just
said claim it changes the dna assessment
false what does it get right it does
change the dna uh but here's why they
say it's false they say it changed the
dna in certain at lab altered liver cell
lines under experimental conditions it
did not assess whether the vaccine
alters the human genome outside of
laboratory conditions
so
i can't even get through it i can't this
study
is checking do the mrna vaccines affect
dna
and the answer is
yes but we're going to rate it false
because it only did so in a study
listen the study only showed that it did
a thing in a study and because the study
didn't show that it does something
outside of study it's false 27
pinocchios
keep your eyes on this one this is going
to be a really important one because you
know the difference between truth and a
conspiracy theory is six to nine months
these days starts out as a conspiracy
theory six months later it's the gospel
truth and i think that timeline is
actually speeding up a little bit
what else did they find i'm just reading
from the ap during the study the
researchers were able to detect dna that
had been converted from the vaccine's
mrna in the lab modified cell still the
swedish study only demonstrated that rna
had converted to dna under particular
conditions created in a lab not a human
body
what the hell do you think you're going
to find you're doing a laboratory study
of course you're only going to conclude
things from the laboratory study well
listen and because the study didn't
prove something that the study didn't
study this is ten thousand pinocchios if
such dna had been incorporated into the
genome as suggested in the false claims
the fear is that it could potentially
alter cell function or lead to cancer in
certain cases but that wasn't observed
in the study hold on this is how this is
how they manage to be so dishonest and
lie about what they've found because
they're saying look the only reason
anyone cares about this is because maybe
it could cause cancer but we didn't find
that it causes cancer no hold on that's
not the that's not the only reason i'm
worried about this
i'm worried about the mrna vaccines
altering human dna
because i don't want it to alter human
dna and because all the people who
pushed these shots told us they couldn't
possibly alter the dna and now you've
got a study here showing that under
certain laboratory conditions on certain
cell lines it actually did alter the dna
but never mind nothing to see here to
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain just like the libs who pushed
the shots told us that there is no way
it's scientifically impossible defy
science that these vaccines could
possibly affect women's menstruation
okay they affect women's menstruation a
little bit okay 42 percent of women are
experiencing changes in their
menstruation after the shots and okay
actually the changes are lasting in many
cases longer than a week which is the
period of time that you you observe
these things to figure out the side
effects of vaccines
okay well never mind pay no attention to
the man behind the curtain trust the
science unless it's a swedish study on
the mrna effect on dna when
this gets you riled up you start
sweating a little bit you're not you've
got to put on your missing and main
clothing right now go to
mizzeninmaine.com use promo code knowles
are you ready to take a vacation might
be your first vacation in a couple of
years are you ready to go hit the links
where you've got to put on mizzen and
main what makes missin and main unique
is they combine the comfort and
flexibility of your favorite athletic
wear with the fit and style of a custom
dress shirt plus their dress shirts are
machine washable so you don't need to be
going to the dry cleaner all the time
and wasting a ton of money and time on a
hot day in the middle of the country
here in nashville tennessee in
washington dc
you you put on that missing in maine you
feel great it was actually the mizzen
main founder he was hanging around
washington dc worked up a sweat running
up the hill in his wrinkled dress shirt
he said there's got to be a better way
he invented a better way i love this
stuff you know i'm very particular about
my style missing in maine has a very
smart style it looks great i love their
polo shirts especially as well whether
you're working from the golf course or
finally taking advantage of your
unlimited vacation policy we got great
news right now if you go to
missingandmaine.com use promo code
knowles k w l e s you will receive 35
off any regular price order of 125 or
more 35 bucks off when you go to mizzen
and main
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n-dot-com
use promo code knowles
the media
want us to hear something different
from joe biden than what joe biden said
they want to rewrite what the president
said
they want to rewrite the studies about
the covid vaccines
and they really want us to eat bugs this
is one of the big
propaganda pushes from the establishment
from the libs from the world economic
forum from hollywood celebrities from
liberal politicians and from the
establishment media for whatever reason
they really
really want you to eat bugs
the future of food is being
revolutionized by science
as new research helps bring unexpected
ingredients to the table
it kind of tastes like shrimp they have
this seafood
quality to them it reminds you of like a
frito or a chip just like crunchy and a
little oily and a little salty and they
taste like popcorn a very smooshy taste
like a pudding almost
like a pudding if pudding were a
disgusting bug
oh hey it tastes like a frito if a frito
were a gross disgusting dirty filthy bug
that you're not supposed to eat
why are they doing this well they're
they're doing this
and they tell you why they're doing this
they're doing this because of global
warming
global warming is really bad
and people keep having babies especially
all those dirty poor brown people in the
foreign countries where we've tried
we've tried our best
to stop them from having children we've
tried to sterilize them we've tried to
give them contraception we've tried to
promote abortion in their countries but
unfortunately their population problem
keeps growing so says bill gates so says
the liberal establishment around the
world darn these guys keep having so
this is going to be a big issue we've
got to get all the poor people to eat
bugs
do you think do you really think
that
bill gates is going to be eating bugs
i don't think so
do you think that clash fob
and his friends at in davos at the world
economic forum do you think they're
going to sit down to a nice big bowl of
bug porridge
i don't think so do you think the
characters the world leaders who made it
down to jeffrey epstein's island
and had nice nice fun bacchanals down
there do you think they were eating bugs
no they were doing lots of creepy things
but eating bugs was not one of them no
the bugs are not for them
the bugs are for you
just like when the liberal elite says
that people need to they need to stop
living in these single family homes
that's why they're going to change the
zoning in san francisco that's why
they're changing the zoning in lots of
cities it's just not it's not efficient
it's not good for the environment you
you're going to have to now live in a
duplex or a quadruplex or a big
apartment building and you're going to
have to live in a tiny little apartment
and that's just important for the
environment
uh they're not gonna live in tiny little
apartments that's just for all of us
that's for all all the rest of us
they're listen you're gonna need to you
shouldn't be flying on airplanes as much
you shouldn't be driving as much gas is
gonna the price of gas really needs to
go up not only is it going up because of
the mismanagement of the world by people
like joe biden and the rest of them
they they want it to go up barack obama
when he was running for president 2008
he said my climate plan will involve
raising the price of gas that is
intentional you have to do that to force
people to get electric cars or to stop
driving entirely and take a bicycle or
take public transportation take a bus
take a train you have to do that do you
think that
the elite are doing that do you think
the elite are eating bugs in their
studio apartment that they're paying out
the nose for that they don't own they're
just renting and then they're getting on
the subway is that what they're doing no
of course not they're eating filet
mignon in their gigantic mansions while
they fly on private jets for very very
short flights flying all over the world
it's you
you're the one that needs to cut back
i'm not going to eat the bugs i'm going
to make you a promise right now
i will never
eat the bugs
ever
oh they're a good source of protein
don't care
oh no the cows are releasing methane
be okay i don't care i don't care at all
i am going to eat the steak i'm going to
eat good ranchers in particular but i'm
going to eat all sorts of meat i'm not
going to eat the bugs
but what's the rationalest reason
michael it's good protein well because
when i eat
i'm not just i'm not just a machine
taking in protein so that i can continue
to function
i'm not just some animal sticking my
face in a feed sack so that i can chow
down on the gruel and go back and work
at the widget factory i'm a human being
you are a human being we live at least
at the moment in civilization and it is
very very uncivilized to eat the bugs
and more broadly it's uncivilized to
just view food to view dining it's such
a central human activity
as just a way to get calories in there
so you can go back and work
work for whom work for
the elite that are not eating the bugs
we need to suffer
so the elite can thrive we need to cut
back and pull back and stop doing and
just to shut up and stay home
so the elite can thrive this is what p
buddha judge
who was in fact you want to talk about
man as machine this guy was in fact
constructed in a laboratory at langley
i'm convinced of that no one can
convince me otherwise i think it was
when george h.w bush was the cia
director he under he he initiated a very
important project it was the build a
buddha judge project and they got all
the screws right and they finally and
then he just one day like frankenstein's
monster he got up he was animated he
said hi hi there hey guys hey what is it
really good that gas prices are really
high
that's really good so because then we
can all drive teslas and uh then that'll
just be great won't it so pete buddha
judge shows up he's in congressional
testimony
and buddha judge says this is really
great
that yeah there's a little bit more pain
on the gas prices but now people can buy
electric cars
the more pain we are all experiencing
from the high price price of gas the
more benefit there is for those who can
access electric vehicles
and who
i can't believe he said it
he just said i hadn't even listened to
the clip that closely last night when i
first came across it he just said
exactly what i said he just said the
quiet part out loud
what did i just say i just said
all the people have to suffer so the
elite can thrive and he actually said
on c-span cameras well yeah
yeah you all the poor all the little
people need to have pain at the gas tank
so that it's a benefit the pain of the
people at the gas tank is a benefit for
those of us who have teslas
who has electric cars
rich people
wealthy people have teslas
normal people don't have teslas yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's really it's really
great and pete is astonished
that anyone would object to this
i'm still astonished that some folks and
and i felt this testifying in congress
yesterday um some folks seem to really
uh struggle to let go of the status quo
yes pete we do some do i think they
gotta send him back to langley and fix a
couple bugs because it's he's
malfunctioning a little bit he's almost
human it's that kind of uncanny valley
he's almost human but he's not quite
there yet i'm astonished that some
people
don't want to let go of the status quo
what he's saying is i'm astonished that
there are people who are in any way
conservative
i'm astonished that people
like their country like their community
like their way of life like their car
like their society like their money like
their property
like their family like
well i'm just astonished maybe pete
butterjudge doesn't like our country
maybe people judge doesn't like our way
of life
i do
i do i don't want to change everything i
don't want to completely upend and
change everything i don't want to live
in a pod i don't want to eat the bugs i
don't want to consume a bunch of cheap
chinese crap i don't want to lose my
political rights i don't want to upend
every single institution i don't want to
change the meaning of man and woman i
don't want to change all my language
like the
american version of north korean state
tv told me to do i don't want i don't
want to do that
you know i don't want to do that and i
don't want you to make me do that pete
buddha judge
or klaus schwab
or dr fauci
or any of these freaking government
technocrats who
who have a much higher opinion of
themselves than we have of them i don't
want to do
any of that i want these people to fail
i want pete bootaj to fail in his job i
want joe biden to fail that i think
that one seems to be a little bit easier
i don't want there to be any sort of
great reset i don't want them to change
the way that we eat and live and
interact with each other and even view
ourselves in our own human nature i want
these people to lose i want to win and i
do think though they have a ton of
institutional power i think the
political winds the the the
understanding of those ordinary people
that they want to force to eat all the
bugs i think
those winds are moving entirely in our
direction
and then one day we're going to die
that's why you got to check out epic
will right now go to epicwill.com use
promo code knowles here is a fun fact
did you know 100 of people will die
the 100 of people who jump at airplanes
will die 100 of people who walk around
the sidewalk will die you're gonna die
okay no one here gets out alive that's
why you need a will that's why you need
a will you do i actually only just
recently
finalized my will
people here at the daily wire finally
are putting their wills together and
that is thanks to epic will will is not
just about you
it's not really about you at all it's
about your loved ones it's about your
family it's about your kids it's about
your stuff it's about what happens to
you and who's gonna have to make the
decisions about what happens to you
someday down the road make those
decisions now so that your loved ones
don't have to face them later go to
epicwhell.com
use promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s save 10
on epic will's complete will package
epic will can set you up with a will in
as little as five minutes which is
unbelievable it is super easy
very very well worth the 119 bucks that
it costs to secure your family's future
it's an amazing price without a will you
might as well wrap up all your money and
your assets and your kids and hand them
over to the state which doesn't care
about you very much no matter where you
are in life
you need to have a will go to
epicwill.com
use code knowles today
on yesterday's show we talked about how
47 house republicans cave to left-wing
pressure on tuesday night to
for no reason whatsoever other than to
give democrats a nice campaign slogan a
nice little campaign clip decided to by
the the new redefinition of marriage
some of these squishes were
very well known but the truth is we can
expect it from those squishes however
i think all of us were a bit surprised
by just how formless some of our elected
officials really are even the ones we
expected more from if you would like to
let your representatives know that you
had not planned on electing the
pillsbury doughboy now is your chance
because
the don't squish t-shirt is here
let your legislators know you are
watching them fold like a wet paper bag
and be trampled on and you don't like
that very much head on over to my store
at dailywire.com
shop today
and most important of all don't squish
also don't forget this month's episode
of bench bureau's book club is tonight 8
pm eastern you will meet up with ben in
israel as he explores leon euris's
historical novel and international
bestseller exodus set amidst the jewish
people's displacement from a hostile
postwar europe exodus is the story of an
american nurse
an israeli freedom fighter and the
rebirth of a nation that had been
dispersed for 2 000 years
we'll be right back with a lot more
welcome back to the show
normal people are pushing back against
the buddha judges
of the world and the radicals and joe
biden who is a vessel for the radicals
even though he doesn't know which end is
up uh two sources have just told cnn
that joe manchin
the moderate democrat who is standing
athwart the libs and yelling stop joe
manchin
will quote unequivocally refuse to
support democrat legislation
related to the sun monster and tax
increases in an economic package
so joe biden has been pushing buildback
better as he calls it the gop calls it
build back broke his his big
spendapalooza policy and manchin said no
not gonna do it not going to do it one
because my constituents don't want me to
do it and two because it's a terrible
package so he says no months and months
of negotiations with chuck schumer and
manchin says nope sorry
not going to do it this is great news
it's great news that you got one or two
semi-normal democrats
people who are willing to buck their
party either because of their moral
conscience or perhaps because they know
that their own constituents don't want
it
either way i'll take what i can get
that's really good news because the
biden economic policy
is a scam it's not going to help the
economy
just just look at how biden's managed
the economy for the last 18 months
this guy took what was a very very
strong economy under trump he took a
great opportunity which is that the the
government voluntarily shut down the
economy for kovid and so when they
reopened the economy it should have
exploded it should have been so amazing
but because of biden's stupid policies
especially especially on energy but but
in other areas as well
because of biden's stupid policies it
hasn't worked so do you think that
spending trillions more dollars do you
think that's going to make things better
do you think joe biden if you give him
more power over the economy you think
that's going to work i don't think so
it's a scam speaking of financial scams
a little bit of a shift here
there was a story yesterday in vice
magazine about a really
oppressed marginalized class of people
that are apparently being scammed and
that class would be
psychics
and tarot readers
and quote intuitive workers and
apparently
scoring device
psychics
and tarot readers and intuitive workers
are under siege
by instagram scammers
scammers are going after the psychics
and the tarot card readers now my first
thought was
if they're really psychics and intuitive
workers
shouldn't they be able to identify the
scammers
shouldn't
shouldn't that be like the one thing
that they are capable of doing so when
someone tries to scam them they say i've
got my crystal ball and no i'm not going
to give you my money
so now the second one and this is what a
lot of people suggested they said
michael you're missing the point the
psychics and the tarot card readers are
scammers
which is is true i'm sure in the vast
majority of cases
it's definitely true in the vast
majority of cases
but
this is one of my more i guess more
controversial opinions
i think some of that stuff is real
psychics and the astrology
and the occult i think that stuff is
real
you know in the bible the bible says
don't do any of that stuff don't consult
astrologers don't get involved in the
occult or with psychics or anything
and i don't think the bible says don't
do that stuff because it's all just fake
and a waste of time
i assume the the reason that the bible
says don't don't do that stuff is
because it's real and bad and
compromises your free will and it's evil
and you shouldn't do it that's why
that's what i think that's what and in
fact this is kind of a little bit of a
tangent but it's a weird personal story
a psychic played
a an unwitting but somewhat significant
role in my reversion to christianity
because i was i was a kind of atheist
agnostic type and i was coming out of it
right at the end of college it was in
new york a little bit and i was just
kind of coming out of it and
anyway one day
i was on a film set and i met this uh
italian
gal and we were chatting and we were
talking about italy and this that and
the other thing and somehow dante came
up and she said oh you know i actually
haven't read dante too much and i said
oh gosh i love dante and he's from this
town and we went here we were just with
this whole long conversation about dante
you know how much i love dante and she
though she's italian hadn't really known
much about him so anyway we leave the
film set weeks and weeks go by
i i then run into her in in an office
building in new york
say oh hey how you doing good to see you
again she looks at me she goes
michael oh i'm so glad i saw you you're
not going to believe this
i so after
we saw each other on that film set i
went to my psychic i said okay sidekick
all right well whatever you know it's
new york okay she goes i went to my
psychic
and
the first thing the psychic asks me is
who's dante
and i got such a [ __ ] because i said
hold on this is the first time you went
there no she had gone to the psychic
many times oh well had you
maybe you had expressed an interest in
dante but i knew she hadn't expressed an
interest in dante that's why we were
talking about it she didn't really know
and the psychic just said who's dante
and that really
spooked me in the way that
c.s lewis describes the difference
between what's what is scary what is
uncanny and what is numinous and he says
you know scary is if you're told there's
a tiger in the other room
and you say that's scary because the
tiger could eat me
and the uncanny is when someone says
there's a ghost in the other room it's
not that you're afraid of what the ghost
is going to do to you
it's that you're afraid that there are
ghosts
and then the numinous is the highest
level of that
which is a you know real religious
feeling the idea of the sublime the idea
that god exists that there is a
providence to everything
all a long way of saying i i do think
that sometimes psychics and
and occult people i think sometimes they
are real you see this in the bible too
even when when saul goes to the witch of
endor
saul says no no one taught no one talks
to the witches anymore but then he
himself goes to this witch of endor and
he says
summon samuel for me
and
uh so she goes and then she's shocked
she says you lied to me you said you're
soul oh my gosh and she's shocked and
there are different ways to read this
passage but one of the ways to read it
that i've heard suggested is that the
witch actually was kind of a scam artist
and the reason she was so shocked is oh
my gosh we actually summoned a ghost oh
man that's super creepy what what's
there a ghost doing here oh man you're
really saul so all of that to say
don't take this stuff lightly folks we
all we all make fun of this there is
more between heaven and earth that is
dreamt of in our philosophy horatio and
the weird cult obsessions occult
behavior
is on the rise you want to talk about
cults there was a video just went viral
of a young
female
slam poetess
and this slam poetist made a point that
i've i bet a lot of people don't she was
in union square
new york a lot of a lot of libs believe
which is she said my god
is a queer god
my god is a queer god
is a queer space
is a safer space
is an allyship with the universe because
my god is self-reflexive and knows that
it is not always a safe space for
everyone at every moment and it may be
an ally to one entity and a trigger to
another so my god is working in
solidarity with everything all at once
and that capacity doesn't fit inside a
body box my god is outside the outside
of a timeless clock my god is
indefatigable my god is intersectional
my god is awake and alert and stays woke
because it once created the universe and
it still encompasses the earth and even
language is transgressive and even
language doesn't properly contain
substance because there is no way to
contractize linguistic labeling with
justice so my god is transcending and
transubstantiating justice my god is
nameless thou shalt not speak my god's
name and speak my god's name in vain to
be anything other than other without any
name because my god is a holy holy holy
intangible amorphous entity of endless
possibility my god is a queer god
and my god
is eternity
thank you
[Applause]
my god is a buzzword
my god is synergy my god is he she they
them
folks ally it's just this whole series
of buzz words reminds me of what harold
bloom the late great literary critic
said about slam poetry which is not just
that it's bad but it is in fact the
death of art
and
and that it is judged by a bunch of
clapping seals in the audience of some
late-night comedy club though it is not
comedy it's not poetry
it's not comedy it's just
it is the death of art but if you listen
past
the the kind of sad performance
if you can get past laughing at this
person and this really awful work of
pseudo art
you hear something that is significant
and actually tells you about the way the
something about the way the left views
the world the first part of that slam
poem the poet test says my god my god is
a queer god my god is all these
buzzwords my god has no body
my god is doesn't fit inside a body
that is a rejection of christianity
that's a rejection of jesus because
according to christianity according to
the religion that animates
our entire civilization
god
becomes incarnate god the son the second
person of the trinity becomes incarnate
takes on flesh and blood becomes man
this is the most solemn moment of the
creed of the creed at the at the mass
and in traditional church services you
you recite what you believe cradle and
unum day i believe in god the father
almighty maker of heaven and earth you
go down and then when it gets to the
middle they say
i i believe that god was conceived of
the holy
spirit born of the virgin mary
and became man
at incarnatus est at home at homo focus
est in the latin and you kneel down and
you take this as you oh my goodness
gracious god becomes
a man
this poetess says no my god doesn't have
a body and then she doubles down on it
at the end of the poem she says my god
is totally transcendent my god doesn't
have a name the god of the bible has a
name the god of the bible has a name
which is
in
actually multiple names but in some
cases there's the unutterable name
yahweh there is uh when moses says who
are you
god says to him and through the burning
bush i am who i am and then of course
god has a name in jesus
and she says no my god doesn't have a
name it's a rejection of christianity
whatever god this woman is worshiping
whatever demon this woman is worshiping
it is not christianity
but it's not nothing either she's not
saying i don't believe in god i don't
worship anything i don't have any
beliefs
because you can't not have beliefs you
can't be neutral
you everybody's got to serve somebody as
that great theologian bob dylan said so
she's saying no i have a god
i just worship a false god
i have a god which is an idol i have a
god and it's in this case
depending on what she means by queerness
it's either my god is sex or my god is
myself or my god is some leftist
ideology whatever it is it's a false god
and whatever it is it is
an object of worship whatever it is you
can't remain neutral this is a point
that kamala harris didn't seem to
appreciate she made this claim the other
day that regardless of your beliefs
regardless of your faith
the issue of abortion
has nothing to do with it
we must also take steps
to protect other fundamental freedoms
including
the freedom
for a woman to make decisions about her
own body
and you know
on this subject
it's important to note
that to support a woman's ability
not her government but her
to make that decision does not
require anyone to abandon their faith or
their beliefs
[Music]
it just requires us to agree
the government shouldn't be making that
decision for her
oh is that what you believe kamala
listen you don't need to abandon your
beliefs
you just need to believe this thing that
i'm telling you to believe which is that
the government has no right and should
not
tell a woman not to kill her kid
kamala what if
what i believe
what if my religion
tells me
that actually
the woman can't kill her kid it's wrong
and the government needs to step in and
stop her from killing her kid what if
that's my belief
then the belief that you're
suggesting
does require me to abandon my belief and
i'm not speaking hypothetically here
either
because that that is a part of my
religion which is called christianity
and that belief is not some new idea
that just popped up in the last 50 years
that idea that abortion is always wrong
goes back
to the very earliest days of
christianity the oldest documents we
have
about christianity and from christianity
tell us that going back to the ddokay
the first code the first kind of
catechism going back to the second
century at least
say abortion's wrong but she's she says
no no that doesn't matter with your
beliefs just you you just have to at a
baseline believe all my beliefs and then
in so much as your beliefs fit in with
my beliefs you're allowed to hold them
the libs believe that their beliefs
are totally neutral
this is the secret
this is the secret that has allowed i
talked about this a little bit in my
book speechless last year this is one of
the secrets that has allowed the libs to
conquer the culture
is we had a culture in america
where you might call it public
christianity it was not a theocracy it
was not a heavy-handed integralist
government or something like that but it
was broadly a public christian culture
christianity was what informed the way
that we viewed public and political life
and then during the 20th century that
was replaced with public liberalism with
public secularism and that became the
dominant ideology
and liberalism and secularism they ain't
neutral there's nothing neutral about
there's nothing neutral about killing
babies there's nothing neutral about
transiting the kids far from any there's
nothing neutral
that about kind of any public regime
that you want to live under but the libs
manage to persuade not only
the left side of the aisle but even many
conservatives
that liberalism is neutral that
secularism is neutral that atheism is
neutral it's not it's a historical it
has nothing to do with the actual
foundations of our country far from it
the actual foundations of our country
very very christian
but furthermore just as a
philosophical matter it ca it can't be
neutral there is no neutrality your
every society is going to have some
sense of what's good and bad and right
and wrong and true and false and you've
got to come to those conclusions
and everybody's got to serve somebody
and if you don't think
if you don't think that you're coming to
those kind of conclusions and making
those statements then you're at the
greatest danger of all because then
you're just being swept away by ideology
unknowingly
speaking of belief
in public health
experts are warning americans that the
united states is not prepared to fight
monkey pox forget about kovid that was
yesterday's news now we're talking about
monkey pox and the u.s is not prepared
now there are not a lot of cases of
monkey pox in the u.s
it's not spreading certainly not spring
like kovid the total number of confirmed
monkey pox cases in the u.s now what a
couple of months after they first
announced it or more is is under 2 000
in the whole kind of country 330 million
people it's less than fewer than 2 000
cases
still the experts here's david harvey
who's the executive director of the
national coalition of std directors he
says america does not have what it needs
to adequately and totally fight monkey
pox we are already stretched to capacity
i think we have exactly what we need to
fight monkeybox here is my i have a
radical suggestion i know we're going to
get a big cdc label fake news medical
misinformation i'm going to say it
anyway this is my
own theory my own medical theory
what if people
just stopped having orgies
what now and
if we're gonna be really specific about
it it's really gay orgies it's the the
monkey pox spreads at bath houses and
gay but let's you know what though let's
be a little more inclusive here let's be
a little more open let's how about what
if we just stop
all the orgies i think that would
probably be good even if the monkey box
threat is not
it's not as great for also
aren't all orgies a little bit gay
it just occurs to me now as i'm thinking
about it because there's only
there's only two sexes
and an orgy by definition involves more
than two people so
somewhere along the line anyway
regardless that's a thought for another
time
what if we just cut out the orgies
you're not allowed to say that
no it's much more important for us to
what
to some extent lock down
to
buy a ton of
vaccines that aren't even for monkey pox
they're going to try to treat monkey pox
with the vaccines for smallpox which has
been eradicated for a very long time uh
we're going to what are we going to have
to mask up again are we going we're
gonna have to have major public health
campaigns what if we just say hey stop
having orgies
don't go to a bath house don't go to a i
think one of them spread at some fetish
conference in belgium or something what
if we just say none of no more of those
stop doing that then we won't have
monkey box
you're not allowed to say that
because it is an aspect of the liberal
creed it is central to the
liberal public liturgy that we have
orgies that we all just are able to
screw whoever we want whenever we want
to do it no matter the risk no matter
the conditions no matter the time of day
okay well that's
call me an authoritarian
call me a fascist
knuckle dragging monster i just think
maybe we should discourage orgies that's
that's my view speaking of irresponsible
behavior
david hogg remember david hogg you might
not remember david hogg he was the kid
who was at the school where there was a
shooting in florida and i don't even i
don't think he was even particularly
close to the shooting itself but he
managed to be one of the first kids to
race to get on television afterward and
he's made something of a career out of
that he managed to get into harvard
strictly on the celebrity that he got
out of uh out of this
tragedy and so david hogg he's been out
of the news for a while he's not really
such a cute kid anymore he's gotten a
little bit older and so now to try to
get some of that celebrity back
he interrupted the house judiciary
hearing to yell and scream about guns
the shooter at my high school
anti-semitic anti-black and racist the
shooter in el paso described it as an
invasion guess what those guns are
coming from the united states of america
they are coming from mexico
they
are
not coming from mexico you are
reiterating the points of a mass shooter
sir sir you are perpetuating this
violence you need to be like a snobby
mouse a democratic
stop these things now
it's sad when the footlights start to
fade
isn't it it's kind of sad for people
when the celebrity starts to go away and
people stop caring you could even tell
there when david's yelling and yelling
he's speaking like he's at a political
rally
but no one was supporting him even his
own guys weren't supporting him so he
was waiting he gets to that point so
these guns are coming from the united
states and he was waiting for applause
and there was no applause and people
weren't even looking at him and then he
starts to stumble on his words there
these are not it's not coming from
mexico it's like a child actor who grows
up
and he was under the misapprehension
that that people liked him because he's
some great actor when really they only
liked him because he's a child
and it's the same thing here this guy
was being used by the democrats because
when he was 16
he was useful to them
and they could put these cute little
kids on tv and the kids were pushing all
the democrat gun talking points but now
you know he's got some whiskers he's
older what is he 19 or 20 now it's just
not
doesn't play as well and so they don't
care this is what democrats do
democrats
use people
when they are useful to them and then
they chew them up and eat them up and
spit them out
and i think it's i don't think i'm being
unfair here i think this is part of the
lib world view that views people not as
children of god maybe the image of
likeness of god with dignity that should
be respected as eternal beings but as
just kind of fodder is just kind of
things to be used for their own benefit
and those things they talk about how
much they love the people and power to
the people but really the people they
need to shut up and eat the bugs and
stay in their little pods and they
shouldn't own anything and because
us great tesla owners we need to be able
to thrive and they need to keep their
mouths quiet and if there's too many of
them and we don't like the way they look
and we don't like where they're being
bored we're just going to kill them
we're going to and we're going to
discourage them from being conceived in
the first place
and they can't have their beliefs
they're going to try to cling bitterly
to their second amendment rights and
their religious views but it's
ridiculous they're just they're nothing
they're nothing to me they should be
cast out into the outer darkness where
there's wailing and gnashing of teeth
that's that's one way of viewing the
world a view of the world that is
divorced from
community from
uh honesty from integrity from from
from the truth from objective reality
that's a vision of the world in which
the truth means nothing and even the
fact checkers are just gonna spin spin
spin and lie lie lie so long as it gives
them more power i'm michael knowles
that's the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the bend shapiro show joe biden
declares he has cancer weirdly while
trying to explain why he's on the verge
of declaring a climate emergency plus
the europeans prepare for a cold and
dreary winter that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen